-Well, thank you all
for coming today.
We're so happy to have
Adrienne Celt here
to read from her first
book, "The Daughters."
And she's going to
kick it off by reading
a portion of the
book and then we're
going to go into a
question and answer.
ADRIENNE CELT: I thought I
would just do a short reading.
I'm really happy to be here
because I used to help run
the "Authors at Google" team.
Which we will talk a little
bit about later, I think.
So I'm going to do a short
reading from the beginning.
This is the prelude.
"All my grandmother's
important stories
took place in the
Polish countryside.
Like this one.
A woman sits nude on
the branch of a tree
and lets her brown legs
dangle into the open air.
The bark ridges cut
pleasantly into her thighs,
and she presses her
palms down, curls
her fingers around the bow.
A man walks towards
her through the woods,
pushing aside whip
thin limbs of birch
and beech, side
stepping shrubs as he
searches for his lost path.
The woman hums a song
and the man's feet
begin to fall in
time with the music.
He does not realize
that this is happening,
does not yet feel his
body enthralled to her.
It is a surprise then when
he catches sight of her legs.
He's far from his village,
tired and thirsty.
The last thing he
expected to find here
was another person,
particularly a woman
who was naked and
glorious and alone.
Her feet are callused,
the souls covered in dirt.
And they hang before
in him like clothes
left to dry in the wind.
He follows the smooth
blue ridges of her veins
up to her calves, her fingers,
her breasts, her neck,
to the soft and downy
lobes of her ears.
When he looks into her face,
she smiles, and his surprise
becomes recognition.
His thirst disappears as
the scent of a nearby river
fills his nose and
mouth, whets his tongue.
The man knows that he's
met the love of his life
and that she is
going to devour him.
This is an old story.
While the aroma of clean
water lingers in the air,
the woman asks the man for
a gift of bread and salt,
which he will feed to
her with his own fingers.
He's already trembling,
imagining it.
His body is vibrating
with desire.
The man shimmies up
the trunk of the tree
and swings onto the
branch beside his beloved.
The closer he gets,
the more she smells
of river currents, the rush
of waves over mossy rocks,
releasing the green
musk of water plants.
Tilting her head to
the side, the woman
beckons him with her fingers.
He leans in to kiss
her, closer, closer.
He bobs his head in time with
her song, and as they embrace,
her humming rumbles through him.
He has never felt so entwined
with someone, so protected.
After a moment, his heart
stops beating and his body
drops to the forest floor
with a muffled thud.
What happened next?
I asked my grandmother, my baba.
That, she said, depends on
who's telling you the story.
Most people don't
understand the rusalka
and so they wouldn't tell you
that she has tears in her eyes
as she jumps down from the tree
and lands softly in the leaves.
They wouldn't tell you of
her heaving sobs of regret
as she walks back to the
river, her body light as air.
But then again, my baba
said, what most people
would tell you is also true.
That she will find another man.
That she will do it again.
She will sit in the
tree and sing her song
as often as she needs
to, take as much strength
as she requires to survive."
-Beautiful.
Thank you for reading.
ADRIENNE CELT: You're welcome.
-So my first question
for you, Adrienne,
is how did you get the
idea for this book?
ADRIENNE CELT: That
is a great question.
-Thank you.
ADRIENNE CELT: So I
started writing this book
in grad school, and it
began as a short story.
And part of the idea of
it-- in a certain sense, it
was an inspiration so I don't
know where it came from.
But I have two grandmothers,
both of whom are Polish.
And one of whom, who I
spent a lot of time with,
was very much a storyteller.
So some of my interest
both in storytelling
as an activity within a
family and also as a way
to pass down information
about culture and family
comes from experience,
even though the stories
that my grandmother told
aren't in this book.
These ones are made up.
-And how long did it end up
taking you to write the novel?
ADRIENNE CELT: I
want to say, all
told, from beginning
to publication,
probably five years.
-Five years.
ADRIENNE CELT: So I started
in grad school with a story.
And then I expanded that over
the course of maybe a year
into a novella.
And then that also
felt too short.
So I expanded that into a novel.
And that, again, took at
least a year or so to revise.
So, you know, it
wasn't like actively
I was writing eight hours a
day during all of those years.
I was also in grad school,
writing other things.
Or I was working.
-Right.
ADRIENNE CELT: But
that was the timeline.
-And in you're in kind
of a unique situation
because you are working also
almost full-time at Google
and writing on the side.
Can you talk a
little bit about how
you balance those two things?
ADRIENNE CELT: Yes, I can.
I have a really strict schedule.
Sometimes I talk to
people who have children
and they say having
a strict schedule is
the only way that I can live my
life and maintain any sanity.
And I actually feel
exactly the same way
even though I
don't have a child.
So I very religiously, so
to speak, write for an hour
every morning before
I start working,
which is possible
because I work from home.
So I can just get up, walk
the dog, write for an hour,
drink some coffee, and then
get started on daily work.
But I also don't
work on Fridays.
So on those days, I either work
all day or go horseback riding,
and then work the
rest of the day.
And then I work a
lot on the weekends.
-Yep.
Yep.
And when you were writing
this, were you also searching
for an agent at the same time?
Or did you finish
the novel and then
go through the process of
searching through and searching
for an agent?
ADRIENNE CELT: I finished a
full draft-- I think, probably,
two full drafts-- of
the novel before I
started looking for an agent.
And then I talked to a
couple of different people,
and based on their feedback,
actually ended up revising it
another time before I went
on another serious search
for an agent and got
signed with my agent.
-Do you have any advice
for aspiring writers
within the Google community
in terms of finding an agent?
ADRIENNE CELT:
Google can help you.
Not the company--
BOTH: The search engine.
-Yeah.
ADRIENNE CELT:
But, first of all,
I would say be really sure that
the book is done before you're
ready to send it out.
I mean, that's different if
you are writing nonfiction.
I don't know as much about that.
I know that that can
be sold on proposal.
In fact, it's usually
sold on proposal.
With fiction, you want
to have a book that
is-- that you feel is as
good as you can make it.
So probably not the first draft.
So first thing I would say,
put it aside for a few weeks
after you're done.
Give it to a couple of people
you trust who are not agents
and have them read it.
And just marinate on what
they say and what you think.
And revise a lot.
But then in terms, like
in a practical sense,
there's a ton of
agents out there.
And so you really want to
not be carpet bombing them.
Although you do want to
contact probably a lot of them.
A good place to start is to
look in the acknowledgement
pages of books that
you like, that you
think are kind of like the
book that you wrote, and see
who those people's agents are.
And that gives you
a starting point
because you can
research their agencies,
see if they have young agents
that also might be a good fit.
And then from there, you can
see who their other clients are.
You can also go to websites
like Poets & Writers
and Writer's Digest, and
they'll have a long list
of agents of all stripes.
Also, being up on, like,
literary Twitter helps.
-What is the literary Twitter?
ADRIENNE CELT: Just
the literary community
as it exists on Twitter.
-I see.
And so you're very involved
with the Twitter community?
ADRIENNE CELT:
Probably too involved.
Yeah.
It gets a little
bit self-amplifying.
But there are a lot of people
on there and a lot of people
who are willing to
conversations with you,
no matter what level you're at.
And there are agents.
You don't mostly want to be
pitching them on Twitter.
But you can get a sense
of who they work with,
and what kind of
person they are,
and what their interests are.
And then when
you're writing them
a query letter, which
is how you actually
get in touch with an agent, you
can mention in the first, like,
sentence or two, like,
I saw you on Twitter
that you did X, Y, and
Z. And that just makes
it a little more personal.
And it lets them know that you
actually did your homework,
and know who they are,
and what they like,
and that's why you're
sending them your book.
Instead of just having them
feel like you're sending
them a "Dear Sir or Madam."
-Right.
And how many query letters is
typical for someone to write?
How many query letters
did you send out?
ADRIENNE CELT: There probably
isn't a typical number.
I probably sent out
20, I want to say.
And of those 20, some
of them were nice no's.
Some of them were
total no responses.
A few of them were really
in-depth analyses of the book
as they saw it.
And then one was my agent.
-And then once you
have found your agent,
how long did it take
until you found someone
to publish the book?
ADRIENNE CELT: I want to
say another couple of months
after that.
We revised it.
And then we send out on a
couple of rounds of submissions
and ended up-- there were
a few different people
who showed interest.
And the person we sold it
to, Katie Adams at Liveright,
was the best one.
-Great.
And so when you were
going through revisions
with your publisher, what kinds
of revisions did they ask for?
How did you change the story?
ADRIENNE CELT: So one
example, just an example
of a revision that we made,
was we cut an entire chapter.
-Wow.
ADRIENNE CELT:
The reason that we
cut it is that my editor
felt, and I agreed,
that it distracted attention
from the main storyline
in a way that really
pulled emotional focus.
One of her really great
insights, I thought,
was that the main thrust of
the story in the present day.
You know, there are a
lot of different threads
in this book-- in the
past, in the present,
in the near past versus the
distant past, et cetera.
And she sort of honed in on
what the most important thing
happening in the present was in
terms of the arc of the novel.
That being the
relationship between Lulu,
the main character,
and her mother, Sarah.
And how bringing that to
a climax and then a close.
-I see.
ADRIENNE CELT: So anyway,
cutting that chapter
helped focus on that.
-As you were talking,
it reminded me
of another question
I wanted to ask you,
which is that the
novel does jump around
between the past and
the present quite a bit
and I was wondering
if you wrote the novel
in chronological order,
if you mapped it out
before you wrote it, if
you just let the words
flow from your fingertips.
What is your writing
process like?
ADRIENNE CELT: So it's
different for everything.
But in this case, I did not
write it chronologically
at all.
I mean, there are
parts of the book
that I did write in the
order that they appear here.
But because there
are so many threads,
and because the
different threads
interact with each other
on different levels,
and can interact with each
other on different levels,
it's actually was a very modular
book as I was writing it.
And so I reorganized it a lot.
And that was part-- that was
another edit that Katie made.
She switched-- the order
of two chapters in a way
that I really liked.
So I do tend to try to
write from start to finish,
but it does doesn't always work.
You can't control it.
-Right.
This book more than-- I'm
working on another book now.
And that book I did write
more in a linear fashion
than this one, I would say.
-And that book, what is
your next book about?
ADRIENNE CELT: My
next book is still
in the process of being written.
So it's still sort of a secret.
But it is on the basic
level about a girl who's
in the wrong place at the
wrong time in a southern border
town in Arizona and
ends up kidnapped
by a couple of
members of a cartel.
And then ends up
on a horseback ride
throughout northern Mexico.
And it's a little bit, you
know, it's an adventure story,
hopefully.
-Right.
ADRIENNE CELT:
But it's also sort
of a meditation on how
much your mind-- how
much of your experience you
can rely on people believing,
and therefore how much what
you experience of something
is true when the
outside world is going
to perceive it a different way.
Which is, actually, although
they're very different books,
I would say that that element is
also present, in a certain way,
in "The Daughters" because you
get the storyline-- the stories
the protagonist is told
by her grandmother, Ada,
about what happened in
their family's history
in Poland are very magical
and mystical fairy tales.
But the same stories are told
very differently by her mother,
in a more realistic,
sort of darker sense.
So, yeah.
-Is there a version of the truth
that you tend to believe more?
Do you align yourself with
the grandmother's version?
Or do you align yourself with
the mother's more realistic
version?
ADRIENNE CELT: For a second,
I thought you meant in life.
-No.
No.
ADRIENNE CELT: I was
like, I don't know
-In your book.
ADRIENNE CELT: I
think I'd probably--
like Lulu, the protagonist,
I sort of hover somewhere
between them.
I think that both Ada,
the grandmother and Sarah,
the mother, have their reasons
for believing that things
happened the way they happened.
And they have their reasons for
saying the way things happened
the way they happened,
which are not necessarily
the same things.
And I think that
their experiences
are as real as any reality,
in a certain sense.
So they are both
important for Lulu,
and therefore, they're
both important for me.
-I see.
Do you have a favorite
character in the book?
ADRIENNE CELT:
That's like asking
a mother with many children.
It's fun to write the bad guy.
So in this book, Sarah is sort
of-- she's not the bad guy,
but she's a dark character.
And so she was a lot of fun to
write-- Sarah, the estranged
mother of the protagonist.
-Was there a
character in the book
that was very difficult
for you to write?
ADRIENNE CELT: I
would say, maybe,
Lulu's husband, John,
was hard for me to write.
-And what was challenging
about writing him?
ADRIENNE CELT:
Partially, just the fact
that in my initial vision for
the book-- because it started
out-- it went through all of
these different permutations
in terms of size and
focus, originally
I had this idea that it would
almost not involve men at all.
And that ended up not
being emotionally realistic
for the book.
But he was a
character that then I
had to do a lot of thinking
about what he meant to Lulu
and what he meant to the story.
So because he wasn't as much
part of my original vision,
I guess, that made it
harder for me to write him.
-So one thing that you
include in the story
is-- well, one of the
main threads in the story
is about music.
Did you have to do
a lot of research
in order to write that
component of the book?
ADRIENNE CELT: Do
you mean you don't
think I'm an opera singer?
-Well, I can tell if
you're an opera singer.
But I was wondering if you
had to do additional research?
ADRIENNE CELT: No.
So I'm not an opera singer.
So a lot of the
book was actually
written before I
did the research
that I am about to describe.
And so the first research
that I did was just--
I did play music
when I was younger
and I have a very passionate
attachment to music.
But I'm not a musician.
I wouldn't call
myself a musician now.
So I did a lot of
listening to music.
A lot of listening to opera.
A lot of reading about opera.
And then I took singing lessons.
I did take voice
lessons with an opera
voice-- like a vocal coach--
while I was in grad school.
And I wouldn't say that I
got really good at singing,
but she kept
encouraging me to try.
She's like, your voice
could hit high notes.
You should try to
hit the high notes.
And I was like, I don't
think you're right.
But that's beautiful
that you think so.
-Yeah.
ADRIENNE CELT:
But in doing that,
I learned a lot about the
physical expression of music.
And I also learned a lot about
the way opera people talk.
Like that.
Not like that.
I interviewed that
teacher as well.
And she gave me a lot of
insights in terms of the opera
world and the idea
of a musician's body,
a singer's body,
as an instrument.
That came in very, very handy.
-Were you sad when you were
finished writing the book?
ADRIENNE CELT: I don't
know because it was such
a long process of finishing.
There was the time that
I finished and signed
with my agent, and
I was just happy.
There was the time when I
sold it, and I was just happy.
And then there were
the edits and I
was relieved when they
were done because they
were kind of on a timeline.
And then after that,
there were copy edits.
And after that, there were
two rounds of proofreading.
So it took a long
time to be done.
And in the middle of all that,
I started writing my new book.
So I don't think I
had as much as the
like postpartum depression.
Which I don't say just
because mothers and children
are a theme in this book.
People really do talk
about it that way.
I don't think I had it as much.
I feel like maybe now that I'm
releasing it into the world,
I'm starting to get to
the end of the period
where it's going to
be exciting for people
to talk about on
literary Twitter.
Now, I'm sort of like, oh,
but it's my book that I did.
Let's always be excited
about it forever.
-Right.
Right.
ADRIENNE CELT: But yeah.
So, I guess, no, but
I feel it coming.
-Speaking about putting the
book out into the world,
as a first time
published author,
what has it been like for
you reading the reviews
and getting feedback
from the outside world?
ADRIENNE CELT: Really weird.
I mean, any writer, once
you get to the point
of being published, publishing
a whole book, for the most part,
you're probably going to have--
and God, I hope for all of you
aspiring writers out there,
you have some experience
with other types of submission
and rejection and acceptance
before you get there-- that it
helps you develop a thick skin.
I have published quite
a few short stories
in literary magazines.
So I know very intimately
the process of being just
rejected out of hand,
or lavishly praised,
or you publish something
and nobody cares.
So, like, I experienced
all that before and so
I didn't anticipate it
being as big of a deal.
But it is a very vulnerable
feeling, in a strange way.
Even if you're used
to having people--
I'm not at all weird about
the idea of people reading it.
That doesn't make me feel sad
or scared or anything like that.
But it is amazing,
that being the case.
And even being able to
be analytical about,
oh, OK, no one review matters.
It's very strange to
see people read-- talk
about it on Amazon or Twitter
or Goodreads or whatever.
And you're just like,
but you-- you're not--
how-- you don't even
know what it's like.
And then you just
think-- you just
have to teach yourself to
put it aside and not care.
Especially since a
lot of the reviews
have been very positive.
And it's just easier to let
that wash all over you--
-Right.
ADRIENNE CELT: --than it
is to let the one guy who
didn't like it wash past you.
-Right.
Do you even read the
negative reviews?
Or do you try to--
ADRIENNE CELT: I try not to.
-Yes.
ADRIENNE CELT: Yeah.
Because it's just not worth it.
-And who was the first person
that you let read your book?
ADRIENNE CELT: Probably one
of my grad school professors.
There were several people
who read pieces of it
in grad school as I
was working on it.
And then my friend Brandon Boyer
White, who is also a writer.
And, although it sounds like
she's a man, she's a woman.
She is probably my first
reader in most things.
-I remember we were working
together when you were actually
working on this story.
Yes.
And I believe that the first
title for the novel that you
had was "Rusalka."
And now it's "The Daughters."
Can you talk about why
you changed the title?
ADRIENNE CELT: I can, yes.
So, Rusalka.
The myth of the rusalka is
a Polish and Slavic myth
about a water spirit.
The excerpt that I
read at the beginning
is actually sort of a
retelling of that myth.
She's sort of a wraith.
So one of my first readers
read the beginning of the book,
and he looked at me-- and he's
very serious literary fiction
person-- and he
said, I knew you were
writing a book about vampires.
And actually, he
was kind of right.
So that's important because
of the Polish history
that weaves through the book.
But "Rusalka" is also
also a Dvorak opera.
So those two elements
ended up becoming
very important in
the book, and so that
was sort of a natural title.
But the reason I changed it, my
publisher wanted to change it.
Not my editor so much as the
marketing team, who you, sort
of, have to do what they say.
And I was sad to change it
but I kind of saw it coming.
Because a lot of times,
people who know about opera
or know about Polish
history are all really sad
that I changed it.
But people who don't
would hear the old title
and say, oh, that's so cool.
Rus-ka what?
And so "The Daughters"--
-It's a little
easier to pronounce.
ADRIENNE CELT: It's a
lot easier to pronounce.
It's easier to remember.
And I still think it
has a very strong tang.
It's a little bit creepy.
It's also lovely.
It's fitting because
there is this lineage
of daughters in the book.
And my only hesitation
about it was
that I feel like there are a
lot of books in the world that
are "The Shoemaker's Daughter"
or "The Bread Baker's
Daughter."
And no offense to those books--
it's hard to title a book,
and I'm sure they
are lovely books--
but I thought that it might
get kind of lost in those.
What I ended up thinking
is that I really
like this title because it's a
little bit different than that.
Instead of focusing
on trying to tag
the women of the
novel to a paternal
figure that they are
the daughters of.
They are themselves.
It is about the
daughters themselves.
And they only come
from one another.
-Right.
Right.
Speaking of the marketing
team's influence
on decisions that were made
about the book, how much say
did you have in
the cover design?
ADRIENNE CELT: The
beautiful cover.
-The beautiful cover design.
ADRIENNE CELT: I
think I probably
had more than some people.
I didn't design it.
The wonderful people at
Liveright designed it.
A lot of people have asked
me if I drew the cover.
And I did not.
But I love it a lot.
They showed me-- I had no
interaction with them at all.
Like I didn't tell
them what I wanted.
I didn't-- nothing like that.
And then my editor
sent me two options.
And one of them was
slightly different
but basically a version of this.
And me and my agent both sort
of leapt all over this one.
And the other one was also nice.
But, I think, they
had been leaning
towards the other
version, which was--
it just looked-- it was whiter.
It looked sort of like stone.
Like it was carved from stone.
But to me, in a small,
like, JPEG version,
it looked like a
wedding invitation.
-Ah.
ADRIENNE CELT: And like,
you know, deckled paper.
And so that was part of why
I leaned towards this one.
-And, well, it's beautiful.
ADRIENNE CELT: Thank you.
People seem to like it.
-Do you have anything
that you wanted
to share with the audience?
I know that you mentioned
something before--
ADRIENNE CELT: Oh, yeah.
- --our talk.
ADRIENNE CELT: Just
in case any Googlers
who are interested in
this are listening.
So I was, as Lizzie
knows, I was one
of the early members of the
"Authors at Google" team.
And I think that one
of the great things
that people outside of Google
don't know about Google
is that there are ways
to sort of carve out
niches within the company for
what you're passionate about.
And a lot of those
end up also being
forms of corporate
philanthropy that
are really wonderful for the
company and for the world.
And I think that something
great that Google could do,
that I would love to
help Google administrate,
would be to set up a fellowship
for young writers, emerging
writers.
So each person-- you'd have
a bunch of people apply.
I'm sure it would be huge.
Social media would
lose its mind.
-So would this--
ADRIENNE CELT: Literary Twitter.
- --would this be in?
ADRIENNE CELT: And they would--
-Sorry.
ADRIENNE CELT: So the
way that I imagine
it, once we picked a
person, or two people, say,
they would come and they would
have an office at Google.
And they would have a
lower salary for the year.
Like a stipend, essentially.
And they would have
office hours, maybe
two or three times a week.
And any Googler
could come to them
to get advice on either their
own personal writing project
or a project for Google.
Whatever.
Just like feedback
from a working writer.
And then the writer could
maybe give a workshop
as well every quarter or
twice a year or something
like that for Googlers to get
expert advice on their work.
And, in return, the writer
would get most of their time
free to work, but
to pursue seriously,
a project which
is very difficult.
When you graduate
from an MFA program--
or if you don't go
to a MFA program--
and you're just trying
to get by on your day job
and you're trying to work
on a book, it's hard.
-Right.
ADRIENNE CELT: You need time.
And it's hard without
recognition or something
that you can sell yourself with.
And this would be a
really awesome thing.
Especially in the Bay
Area, where there's already
so much great focus on things
like the Stegner program
at Stanford.
-What's the Stegner program?
ADRIENNE CELT: It's
something similar
but it's embedded within
a university setting.
-I see.
ADRIENNE CELT: Yeah.
And would these
be internal people
who would apply for
this fellowship?
Or would they be external?
Or would it be
open to everybody?
ADRIENNE CELT: Open to
everybody, I would think.
-Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]